>>Well the world situation is not in the best
shape right now. I think we have major problems
in every aspect of our human activities. And
the economy is going down the drain. There
is a major rift between different parts of
the world. That we have number of wars going
on. The humanitarian situation in many places
like Darfur like Gaza is, is blocked from
our conscience. And I think we are here to
pick up the pieces. I have a lot of hope.
That was, [second pause] that Obama Administration
that things will change. We know we have the
financial crisis and we have to do a lot to
fix the financial crisis, but a lot that we
can do in the political arena does not require
money. Reaching out to each other, engaging
in a dialogue, build a system that is rooted
in equity. Where I cannot see how we are ever
going to have security where we have one-third
of the world population live on less than
two dollars a day. We have places like Darfur
where people are dying by the hundreds every
day and we continue to wring our hands. So
we need to strengthen our financial, our international
institutions. We need to have a robust system
to prevent conflict, to manage conflict. We
need to deal with this whole new state ranging
from moving towards nuclear disarmorment,for
the weapons state to create the environment
that nuclear weapon does not bring power,and
prestige, and influence,but we need a system
that does not depend on nuclear weapons. We
need to deal with a specific concern: North
Korea, Iran. We need to multi-nationalize
the fuel cycle so no one country have the
technology to develop nuclear weapon in short
span of time, and of course we need to address
the most serious concern of all, Which is
nuclear terrorism. The possibilities that
extremist groups will get their hands on nuclear
weapon. If they do that they will obviously
use it and a good part of our civilization
would be lost. So there's a lot of challenge,
but there are also a lot of opportunities.
It's all a question of mindset, what kind
of values we would like to live by and as
I keep mentioning here in Davos, for the first
time I have hope that we are in a position
to establish a saner, a safer, a more humane
world. With the new administration a system
that is based on inclusiveness that are not
exclusiveness. A system that is based on talking
to our enemies before we talk to our friends,
and respect each other simply as human beings
irrespective to our ethnicity, or religion,or
color. So it is a new beginning and every
one of us has a responsibility and every one
has to do what they can in spirit of activity
to create finding a world when we all believe
that we are one part of a one human family
and if we want to succeed we're going to succeed
together and if not we are also going to fail
together.